Hello.
Welcome back. It's the third of the four
sessions on chapter three.
So, we'll have today on chapter three
looking at some of the sections,
figures, formalisms, questions.
Um
Fraser
will have the last of the chapter three
sections later in the week. Maybe with
some questions
uh
or other things built out by then.
Then for the next 2 weeks we'll head
into chapter four.
So,
um
if we pull back to
this first figure.
We're still in this first part of the
fundamentals.
And there's been this stepwise move from
the thought experiment in chapter one
to just hidden state estimation
in chapter two, latent state estimates,
which is essentially like prediction.
Now we're in chapter three combining the
learning and the inference like sort of
thinking fast and slow with the faster
pass-forward like
inference, real-time inference,
perception like and then the slower
learning like inference like training a
model or fitting a model.
Not just doing the quick
uh
flow inference.
Staying within a variety of non-free
energy based statistical methods
for these kinds of modeling topics in
the first chapters.
Chapter four is where the variational
methods and like free energy values and
things like that are going to be
introduced.
So, that's what we'll get to
in the coming weeks. But
in this last bit of three
we're going to talk about some more
conventional or complementary or
alternative statistical methods
for essentially fitting a model from
data
and then using the model
to fit data but in a sort of like faster
pre-trained way.
Anyone want to start with like a section
of three or a question
from three to start with?
Or take a
you know, write down your question or
thought.
>> Um maybe I can just make a remark about
last time we spoke about which X is
observed. Is it actually the X star from
the environment or the X from the agent?
It seems to me that
the star is deliberately omitted because
and this is just my understanding that
the X being considered observed is
simply because
we have this two-part action to first um
estimate an X and then use that X to
estimate the values the latest updated
values of the parameters.
So in that sense
knowing what we have X X what we have
estimated X to be in the previous um
iteration in effect makes X observable
uh for the you know,
currently observable.
So that's why I think X does not have
stars in in this chapter
you know, when it's called observed.
>> Thank you, Andrew.
>> Um yeah, um
so so for clarity and I'm sure we can
get into it more, um, but part of
treating X as unobserved
what whenever we state it is unobserved
in those sort of like tables like like
table 3.4 or otherwise where we're
listing out here's what's observed,
here's what's not observed, here's
what's probabilistic, here's what's
treated as deterministic um, whenever we
actually get into expectation
maximization and we have this two-step
profit, uh, process of inference over X
and then learning over theta or our
parameters um, during that initial
inference step we're doing exactly what
we did in chapter two, we're just
treating, uh, the X as unobserved and so
we have to infer it, uh, using the
parameters in our model in addition to
the new sample or set of samples of
observations that we receive and then in
the second step of expectation
maximization whenever we do learning
it's there that we have to sort of treat
X as if,
uh, it were given, right? We have to
treat it as if it is something that
known. It's like, well, if X
hypothetically was known then now how
can we update theta our parameters, um,
given the the X in the sample? So, it's
kind of like in in step one in that E
step we do inference, we use the
parameters in our Y in order to infer
our X. In the second step, the
maximization, the M step, that's where
we use our Y and our X to infer
parameters. So, you can kind of see how
this becomes like a looping process.
Um,
now that all of that said, uh, in
reference to a previous session
regarding the asterisk, um,
I think that it might be a a outdated
draft that did not properly use the
asterisk where it should appear, but the
X asterisk definitively sort of always
refers to the true environmental state
that that that comes out of the true
generative process, not the agent. And
so whenever we're doing these EM steps
and so on and inference when we're doing
learning, all of that's with respect to
and relative to the agent. And so at
never never at any point do we assume
that the agent has any direct access to
X asterisk, right? It never has direct
access to the real environment's state.
And so it can only infer it. So really,
the only kind of things that the agent
ever receives outside of itself, cuz
inside of itself is its inference about
states X without the asterisk, and then
also theta, the parameters. The only
thing that the agent ever really
receives from outside of itself are
those observations, the Y, which, you
know, hopefully relate to X so that the
agent can kind of build and infer and
learn a good model. Um but that's all it
has. So it's never getting direct access
to X asterisk or the environment at any
point.
>> Thank you, Fraser.
>> Yeah, I completely second all that,
Andrew. It is a little bit confusing
maybe by the fact that in the first half
of the chapters that what I what I
covered in my session last week, section
3.1 to 3.3, we actually do assume that
we can see the true hidden state and we
learn a mapping between the hidden state
and the observations.
Uh and then that's that's where we spin
up our story about learning the model
parameters. That is not in general the
epistemic situation that we're in, very
much as Andrew said. So we're going to
have to do away with that assumption now
and see how we can do
the how we can still conduct the
modeling with the learning of our model
parameters and the so the actual answer
given that we we really don't have
access to the hidden state is that we do
expectation maximization. So that's
really the the culmination of today's
session, hopefully.
>> Yeah,
these are these are great comments.
I'm also reminded of the
this
paper and uh
discussion with Ran Wei
about partial observability
and it's the sort of punchline is that
the agents doing a partially observable
model
where they are explicitly modeling their
observations and their beliefs about
latent space like their belief their
thermometer readings and their beliefs
about temperature
and separating out agent's beliefs about
temperature which is X from X star
the true temperature of the room
which is mediated
with an observation noise and is like
two jumps away
from observations
that
the partially observable model
all of its parameters are observable.
But one of those variables has to do
with partial observability.
So from the agent's perspective, they
can kind of fit this model of
uncertainty
observing this model of uncertainty.
So it sounds like a little bit strange
or um
or uh unnecessary partitioning but it's
actually another way to approach that
um nexus of like legible modeling of
uncertainties
and being able to do statistical
modeling on latent spaces because this
this question is like, well,
but
if all we know is thermometer readings
and our beliefs about temperature,
how is that how is that going to be
based in any way with the actual
temperature in the room?
And so that is kind of the setting that
is is going to be
discussed.
Like the the partially observable model
is fully observed by the modeler,
but it has a semantic referent of
something that is only partially
observed by the agents.
It's kind of like you could design a
multi-agent setting or single-agent
setting where the agent has like kind of
tele-
telepathic uh you know, or observability
of the environment.
Like some variable from the environment
is just being injected into its belief
updating.
Or you can use this kind of uh approach
to model a more epistemically
limited agents,
which as Fraser pointed out, like that
is the main situation that we want to
know.
Where we want to have the simulation
tracking each agent's belief about
temperature and one true
actual temperature
in the room
and explore all the different ways in
which the the different agents could be
processing the same or different
observation sequences into different
beliefs about latent steps.
Okay.
>> Should we maybe want to talk about
linear Gaussian systems or are there any
questions there about cuz that's kind of
the first section of this uh
well, that that we're starting out with
now, 3.4.
>> Yep.
>> Really generalizes everything we did
um, in 3.1 to 3.3.
>> Yep. Yeah. So, yeah, we have talked
um,
so far
about the, um,
mainly the sections 3.1, 2, and 3
with a Bayesian linear regression.
So, kind of using this regression type
way to fit observations coming in
with, um,
their their latent value.
And that's that can kind of be discussed
in a, um,
in a frequentist least squares
classical
regression setting. It can also be
discussed in this Bayesian linear
regression
framework. That takes us up to figure
3.11.
And the end of section, um, 3.3.
Then we get to the second half of, you
know, the bottom of the third.
And 3.4, which is to
linear Gaussian systems.
So,
um,
he writes,
"Having explored the learning process
parameter estimation in detail in the
last section, we return our attention to
the inference process, hidden state
inference. So, having completed the kind
of model training slower step,
now
return to the fast inference step.
This exposition of hidden state
estimation focused either on a single
state and sample or a single state with
multiple samples.
We will now expand this concept to the
multivariate state."
So, it's kind of like everything that
was being discussed in terms of just one
sensor, either with a sequence of
observations or one observation, is
pretty,
um,
straightforwardly generalized like a
vector of observations.
So, instead of just having one
thermometer,
it you could have multiple
thermometers,
um sometimes also called sensor fusion.
Then,
there are these different special cases
or configurations
of this broader family. So, we know that
we could do single sensor single data
point or we could do multi-sensor
multi-data point.
Now, what are we going to do with that
multi-sensor multi-data point data set?
Fit some kind of statistical model.
What kinds of statistical models?
The ones that are named here.
Which correspond to a lot of the major
and common statistical
um techniques
in
what are separated at a kind of top
level into supervised and unsupervised
learning.
Um all of us unsupervised learners here.
But, supervised learning is where you
have labeled data.
So, you have, for example, some set of
images that correspond to a healthy or
to a diseased state, and you're able to
fit different methods that are based
upon that
labeling
and kind of training the model to
recapitulate a get to fit a given
label classification, for example.
Unsupervised learning
doesn't come in with as much of a
contrast of approach, and it kind of is
like um it's like an answer to an
unasked question. Like, principal
component analysis
is not doing hypothesis testing.
It looks for just intrinsic
patterns in the relation of the data,
and for for standard principal component
analysis like just focusing on that
example,
there's just one deterministic output.
Even a very large data set, just with
the same Python or R method that does uh
PCA, you will get the same PCA output.
In terms of like how much which which
are the dimensions and what are the
different locations of the data points
in those dimensions.
Um
it's it's slightly um do depending on
how it's implemented, some of these
other ones can become a little bit more
like needing uh random seed to be fixed
to be reproducible.
But um PCA is kind of like the exemplar
of unsupervised learning.
Where it's just like if you know you
have the data sets of the cat and the
dog photos,
supervised learning is you show the
statistical model the labels and it fits
like a support vector or some
differentiator between the data points
or patterns that are associated with cat
or dog in order to do well at
classifying and having like a low false
positive and false negative rate on
the training data or on a test sample of
images.
Whereas
the PCA is just going to like project
those images into clusters or whatever
shape.
And then secondarily, you could um
do these kinds of more differentiative
analyses.
But unsupervised, it's like you can
almost imagine the strengths and
weaknesses.
Which is it's not as goal-oriented, it's
sometimes not as interpretable,
but it sometimes can be like a richer
and less
biased a priori way to describe
different data, so it's sometimes used
like in early stages of processing like
sensor fusion.
Um but
in terms of section 3.4,
it's just kind of like a wow moment
because
it's like saying
the machinery that we discussed earlier
is going to be extended with continuity.
And then there are some
powerful ways which will get revisited
as well
to look at like experimental design
and the way that the experimental design
can structure large matrices
whose operations among them
can
in um are the implementations of some of
these statistical methods.
Andrew?
>> Yeah, thanks. This is This is slightly
reiterating some of what Daniel said,
but um
yeah, it's
it's it's good to bring in the the
terminology regarding unsupervised
versus supervised learning. And exactly
as Daniel said, it's like effectively if
you're going to do some kind of image
classification model, then if you
actually give it the true labels of cat
and dog, like you can think of that sort
of is like that's the true state, the
true X. And then the the the Y, the
observation, the data itself are the
actual images of the cats and dogs,
right? So, you can imagine like you have
the you have the actual data, the Y, and
then you actually have the true state or
the true label, cat or dog. And so, if
we were to train a model where we do
give it the true X or the X asterisk, so
to speak, then we're giving the model
direct access to the environment. And
then the idea from there, from a
standard machine learning standpoint, is
well, you have this sort of training
data that you're giving it with a lot of
true values. And then the hope is that
you can kind of estimate the parameters
uh for for that model to where now you
have this nice model, sort of like a
learning step. And then after that, you
can deploy that model going forward, and
hopefully it generalizes well enough
that it can make relatively accurate
predictions going forward despite the
fact that you're never giving it any
further training data
unless you were to do something like
that. You could give it some kind of
additional training data or have to have
it do some kind of online learning where
it's typically an active inference where
we're in this unsupervised domain where
we don't know the true state. Right? So
we're always having to to make an
inference over what the true state is
and then furthermore that brings up
another sort of issue that I just see
conceptually come up in these kinds of
conversations like does the model of the
agent have to match the model of the
environment or does it ever and like
given that we never know the true X
and we might not even necessarily know
the true model parameters either.
We're we're effectively always having to
infer all of these things and learn all
these things which also means that
it actually seems more likely I'm saying
that in a colloquial sense not
necessarily in a in a in a
computed sense but it seems more likely
that the agent won't end up with having
the same exact model as the environment
has.
I conceptually in some other areas of
active inference we start thinking about
things like how does an agent maintain
its homeostasis.
You know the agent wants to eat food but
the environment doesn't care if the
agent eats food or not then to some
degree it might be necessary for an
agent to have a non-identical model to
the environment. It might just be that
the agent needs to learn the environment
well enough so that it can sort of
operate and continue to exist or survive
in that environment. But yeah I just
wanted to give a a little bit more
additional sort of conceptual context
around
around these things.
>> Yes. Giacomo asked where where does
non-parametric regression fall?
Supervised or unsupervised? I mean I'm
I'm not not making overly umbrella
statements, but whether it's
fitting with
whether the regression slope is being
fit with classical frequentist
reducing sum of squares
Bayesian regression
or a non-parametric approach like the
bootstrap or the jackknife or resampling
or other approaches
whatever that is being fit that
regression line is being fit with
you're getting some input data with X
and Y.
So it could be um
percentage of red pixels in the image
and zero or one like a binary regression
whether it's a cat. So a labeling
problem is like a regression with some
variables on the Y
and then the X is the the labeled image
like a categorical regression to to put
it in that um way.
Whereas if
you were going to do an unstructured
um or unsupervised data analysis
you would just have the observations
like just the images of just the images.
And then they might fall out upon
secondary visual analysis or upon some
kind of principled K-means clustering
that there's
differentiative clustering of data
points.
But even in that situation where it was
a totally as separate as could be these
two clouds of data points like the
cleanest possible situation
still the PCA isn't going to tell you
that per se.
It's just going to tell you the location
of those data points
and then through exploratory data
analysis or secondary methods you could
determine that there was a
differentiation and then basically you'd
be doing
a a supervised like with cluster
membership
observation of the raw or transformed
attributes of the data point against
um cluster membership.
And then you wrote unsupervised learning
is extracting implicit dimension
eigenvectors to explain data variation.
While supervised is projection onto a
known space of vectors.
Probably basically, yes. I think there's
other implicit info that might not be
just eigenvectors, but in the case of
the PCA
um and and related methods, yes, it
definitely is.
But it could be like on a transform or
like a higher moment or something like
that. But broadly, yes, intrinsic or
implicit information in the data.
Supervised is projecting into a known
basis set.
Or um
it's like, you know, there you have the
observation and then
um
how they map to
states which are taken as good
informative observations. You get into
the sort of like Maxwell demon. That's
like the adversarial case.
Is looking at a statistical method, it's
like how bad how how would how well
could you perform if you were given this
like improbable
but possible adversarial sequence of
uninformative observations.
And like people explore things like
that.
And then Andrew wrote, "The point of
unsupervised setting is at no point does
a model get access to any true
relation, but you have to interpret it,
yeah." So you're just given a folder of
images.
Should there be two? Should there be
cats and dogs? Or should there be two
subcategories or three? It's like you
don't even know.
There might be a uh uh
trivial convergence answer to that.
There might be multiple or very um
ambiguous answers to that, but it's like
how many categories should there be of
these images?
And you could say, "Well, just one. All
of them are in one cluster." Or each
image is its own cluster.
Both of those extreme answers are
probably not much more useful than
saying nothing.
So then the question is
what would be something that explains
data, but also gets penalized for having
too many parameters?
Because adding more parameters to a
statistical model
like a regression um or a neural network
it's basically always going to explain
the data better.
Every principal component that you add
in will by definition saturate more
variance and explain the training data
better.
So then there's a trade-off of whether
it's approached through different ways
including free energy minimization
where you want to pick the model
with a number of parameters
that's at a sort of Pareto optimal or
kind of Goldilocks zone with explaining
the data and being penalized for having
too many parameters, which is like the
accuracy minus complexity trade-off.
Okay. So that
3.4
uh
says
the linear Gaussian
is going to cover a lot of these
statistical
um
families.
3.13
is
um says
the mixing matrix tells us how the
elements of some input vector of state X
linearly combine to produce an output
vector of observation Y.
So this kind of speaks to um
how the word linear is being used here.
There are straight-line linear models.
However, linear actually refers to a
linear combination
of different statistical elements.
So like a coefficient in front of some
other elements that are added together.
So it doesn't mean that it can only fit
points on a line.
It just means that there's an um
sort of additive
effect
across different variables, which can be
extremely expressive.
>> [snorts]
>> So, it doesn't mean it's just X on Y.
Like
linear Gaussian systems
include high-dimensional
and  non-linear methods in a way.
Like, for example, polynomial
regression.
I mean, it's it's
a like a quadratic equation is a
non-linear.
But, it actually is a line
in the sense that
it is it is aligned, but it's not a
straight line.
But, it still is within this framework
of linear Gaussian systems because even
if you had like a fifth-degree
polynomial, like X to the fifth plus
some number of X to the fourth plus some
number of X to the third, to the second,
to the first, and a constant,
each of those coefficients
could be understood of it as in a linear
mixture.
And, so that's what makes it a linear
Gaussian system, not whether it looks
like a straight line drawn through data
points,
but whether you have this mixing matrix
that ha um
that
is
with a certain um kind of composability
linearity property.
So, it can be represented this way,
modified, and trained, and everything
this way.
But, it's a a good short kind of motto
to keep around is that the linear
Gaussian system doesn't mean
just a straight line
drawn through a two-dimensional data
cloud.
Okay. Three um
3:14 I think it'll be fun to see
these methods in the code, plus make
make some other ones, um,
ourselves
and look at other existing like
multi-agent reinforcement learning
environments.
But I wonder like this kind of game
environments, what other code examples.
Um, but that's like it's just kind of a
one-off that there's like this game
world. So just curious to see if it's
going to come back later in the textbook
or software.
Um,
um, example 3.6 goes into this
situation
where the agent has a prior on the food.
And then, um, so that's this is
essentially equivalent to
um, this setting.
Like having a prior on where the food is
and then observations come in and then
updating either just
assessing how surprised you are purely
by the observation itself.
And like relative and absolute surprise
in finding or not finding the food in a
given location and then also the slower
process of updating your prior to the
um, to to update your beliefs about
where the food is.
Okay.
Um, figure 3.15
shows that.
So 3.15
here's
the actual location of the food
and here's the previous location.
That corresponds to the previous
location and the
um, actual.
And
and then the last part of that example
3.6.
The posterior distribution over X the
agent is the agent's best guess about
the location of the food with
uncertainty. It's shown in the heat map.
We We see the mean of the distribution
is slightly smaller under the true value
due to the small sample size.
The prior distribution is unlikely to
have made a huge contribution after 20
samples.
So, this is where we get into like the
relative influence of priors and kind of
like precision waiting whether new
observations are just instantly
um moved to or whether there's more
recalcitrance in updating priors,
which is better for a noisier setting
but is slower in a more predictable
setting. That's like the common filter.
And just showing that we can adapt that
to these kind of getting into the
behavioral and cognitive settings. For
sure.
>> Yeah, could you go to figure 3.13 again
just real quick? Uh the mixing matrix.
So, yeah, this I mean
this this is a meant to be a visual just
for those who don't have the text
available and maybe who watching this
later. The idea is that look we have our
state vector. It's in this case a three
element state vector. So, it's a list or
you know, a vector of three things.
The idea is the mixing matrix is going
to tell us how the elements of that
vector how those three things like
combine so as to produce the observation
on the left the Y kind of or on the
right, sorry.
So, and it you know, the mixing matrix
theta it's just it's just a a matrix of
of numbers that say in what proportion
should I
uh take element one from X and quote mix
it or add it to the second element of X
and so on and so on so as to generate
the observation. That's kind of why it
means mixing.
Uh you know, at least um intuitively.
So.
>> Yes. And like
X R3 saying these are real numbers and
there's three dimensions of them. So,
this doesn't imply like a XYZ um
spatial
but you could kind of imagine that. Like
this could be it's it's our agent's
belief about the X, Y, and Z coordinate
or polar coordinate um or quadrant
coordinate for location
with a four-channel observation or
something like that. But then you could
have arbitrary sensor fusion where it
could be trying to infer
three-dimensional
value from a one-dimensional. Like,
you're trying to predict the RGB value
of a pixel from a grayscale observation.
Well, right off the bat, you can see
like when you're trying to predict more
latent states than you have observations
you're going to end up with like these
pathologies or something where there's
colors that you couldn't differentiate.
Um unless, for example, you had a strong
prior on on what colors palettes were
already used. And then if you had
another situation like you're observing
the RGB and you're just trying to infer
the grayscale
then it's kind of like overdetermined.
And then there's everything in between
where there's everything from like just
slam dunk
sensor to latent state is just like a
super fast small calculation on small
matrices with with perfect success in
practice um or even in theory
ranging to situations that are like
systematically
implausible to make certain conclusions.
Like, an example of that is the gene
expression analysis
where you might have an experiment where
there's like eight samples
and 20,000
observations per sample.
And so that's going to have a totally
different shape of the matrix and
different statistical properties. But
those are all kind of
encompassable
in this
mixture model where there's like a
signal-to-noise plus mixture
with a lot of configurability. Fraser?
>> Yeah, just one last thing. Uh so, with
respect to the mixing matrix, a big
factor is, you know, it's some matrix in
R to the D times C, right? So, this is
telling us how many
how many rows and how many columns we
have. The D, if you go to page 399 in
the appendix mathematical notation and
modeling setup, table B2 tells you what
these dimensions are. So, D is always
used to refer to the observation
dimension. So, in this case, D is four.
We you know, the observations we have a
dimensionality of four, and C is the
dimensionality of the hidden states
which in this case is three. So, that's
that's what this D and C means, and
again, page
well, table B2 on page 399, that's those
conventions. So.
>> Yeah, that's a great comment.
Page 399.
Up.
D is
observation dimension.
C is
hidden state
dimension. Not to be confused with a C
preference constraint POMDP, you know,
they're just symbols.
And then B, not to be
a B, not to be confused with B
is
>> [laughter]
>> autonomous state dimension. Because
that's how action's going to enter the
situation is what I'm doing or what I'm
about to be doing, which is what I will
be doing at that time. Those or what
they will be doing at that time or what
will be happening at that time causally.
Action
Yeah, it's going to but we haven't
gotten there, but that's how action is
going to be brought in in a unified way
to perception.
That's the whole Holy Iguana joint
cognitive modeling, perception,
cognition, internal states, action,
joint modeling of that distribution,
like even handling of all those
different distributions, which ones are
fixed, which ones are variable, all
those kinds of things
because of the even handling of
observations
and hidden states of the agent's
perspective. So, that's the partial
observability.
That's like a partially observable
Markov process.
And then
we can introduce the action and
decision-making like the active
inference decision process control
theoretic component. Now, that's like
the
partially observable Markov decision
process.
So, just like the the partial
observability is up here.
This is the action modeling
process.
That's how it's all going to kind of get
brought together within this
linear Gaussian setting.
Which we could
to fit that model
we have like the kind of three options
of the classical statistical parametric
method, the Bayesian regression method,
and the non-parametric method.
And then chapter four, we're going to go
into a variant of the Bayesian approach
with the variational methods and that's
going to bring in the free energy and
all these kinds of like loss functionals
for fitting that
inference problem
in a really powerful flexible way.
But, it's good to like kind of um at
this base camp chapter three level
kind of reground and consolidate with
like what's the statistical setting
outside of bringing action into the
picture
though we know it will come into play.
And then just how are we making clear
the difference between observables and
unobservables?
Because that's like the fundamental.
And then the causal status and all the
graph structures are essentially
arbitrary and there's like limited
conventions or a given experiment may
have a pretty obvious causal structure
or observational structure.
So, it's like the balance between
the open-endedness of all those possible
observable and unobservable connections,
which is open-ended by by
design and and by the way it should be.
And then the specific data set, which is
sometimes like you're just handed a
spreadsheet in a very certain way.
Pressure?
>> Yeah, absolutely. I just one last thing
and then maybe we should get on to
expectation maximization, but
it it said in the book, look, what you
want for this process to to work well is
you want your observation dimension to
be bigger and actually quite a lot
bigger than your hidden state dimension.
So, the idea is that you want to be able
to have many different ways to sense the
same hidden state, right? And you know,
we we sort of see this intuitively, like
if you can if you can hear, see, touch,
and smell something, that's usually
pretty good evidence that it's there as
opposed to if you can only see it,
right? So, that's that's kind of a
crucial
uh thing to keep in mind when talking
about
doing this this kind of linear Gaussian
stuff, so.
>> Yeah, like yeah, multiple modalities
with confirmatory streams of evidence,
that's its own kind of um
that's like its own advantage, but then
also even within a modality, like
imagine
which one of these situations is
preferable? One thermometer and you're
trying to infer the temperature at 100
locations on a grid
or 100 thermometers in one location on
the grid?
Or like do you want uh sample or sensors
like thermometers that have a lower
noise, all things being equal, or
higher? Or have more accuracy? Um this
is kind of like accuracy and bias.
Classic classic statistical image.
High and low accuracy, high and low
bias.
With that, accuracy is whether it's a
tight cluster, high accuracy, or a loose
cluster, low accuracy.
And then bias being when it is either
um with reference to the true values or
underlying distribution. So, you know,
not not reading heavily into this this
term or using in the broader uh
important way.
But like unbiased is when it's
targeting the middle of the bull's-eye
with higher low accuracy. Biased if it
has like a systematic
um directional bias in the X or the Y
direction.
Okay.
So,
3.
5 gets into expectation maximization for
factor analysis.
So, from our linear Gauss linear
Gaussian um
we're going to see
here's this EM two-stroke engine.
Where we're going to be um
kicking it off
with
as if we have the theta unknown.
The first you enter into this cycle by
setting an M.
Or in the M step by setting your initial
theta.
That theta estimate gets passed to an
expectation
two-stroke engine that is described on
uh page
70.
That's going to get
explored in the context of the factor
analysis.
But EM is a pretty broad algorithm that
like directly and in sort of um
uh
spiritual cousins uh or or derivative
implementations, like that kind of
two-stroke engine back and forth,
like a zigzag optimization. It's just an
idea that comes up a lot, but EM is a
specific but broad category
that's used under the hood by a lot of
data fitting
methods in in statistical packages and
stuff.
So, factor analysis,
um
there's three listed here, but there's
other subtypes of factor analysis.
There's the deterministic
and the probabilistic variants of
principal component analysis.
And also this huge, um kind of hiding in
plain sight, hidden state estimation.
Which is like any mapping where X is
just a value. R1
is just saying it's a it's a real
number, and there's just one value. It
could be discrete,
it could be um within a certain range,
it could be continuous, but it's just
going to like project from whatever we
have down to one value.
But then you can have a vector of those.
So, this would be like any situation
where we have like kind of archetypal
blends.
And then like
they're
you're getting observations,
but we don't observe ever that
archetypal blends
that's leading to that data points being
generated in a likely-ist way.
So, that's what makes it overall on the
unsupervised.
Is we're only going to look at
information within the observation set,
within the data set.
And then
um
it is going to separate out based upon
these loadings of these latent factors.
Um
So, 3.5 is going to do expectation
maximization, this two-step process,
which could be applied depending on the
special cases of how these
[clears throat] parameters are
constrained or variable or whatever,
into all of these other
types of unsupervised learning
techniques.
But here is just being focused in
essentially like a PCA-like
method.
And I think like looking into how PCA
works
is a good
step.
Um 3.5
1 describes the generative model.
3.52 starts with the writing out the
joint distribution.
Then goes into the E and the M step
themselves on page 72.
And algorithm 3
is the pseudo code algorithm.
So I'll just
here
copy that in.
We'll we'll we'll do better with with
copying the uh
algorithms into a table and all that.
But this is the
um
pseudo code.
Now, very awesomely for for those in
2026 and and beyond we hope, like you
could paste that into an LLM
and just say implement this pseudo code
on blank. Or describe this to me like I
was making a cake.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
you know, or something like that. Like
the pseudo code is the and so that helps
step in to all this distance between the
analytical or the mathematical or the
formal components, which are like
equation 3.4 3.45
46, and then this is like more from the
computer scientist perspective.
So if you imagine like more targeted
generative educational materials or or
future textbooks or whatever, like you
could have more of a algorithm driven
way to think about procedurally how
these things are done
with all of their like for if while
logic
or you could have more of and or more
mathematically
like notation driven approach.
But notation to implementation can be a
massive gap. Like it's literally it's
easier said than done situation.
We're just like oh but here's this prior
here's the posterior. I mean how hard is
that going to be?
But that could be a huge challenge.
So it's like
approached from multiple ways
in the pros and in the notational math
and in the algorithm and in the code
itself.
Because even going from the pseudo code
like this recipe
that's like what we what we sometimes
talk about like like making a recipe
that you can't cook.
You'd say you know
while you have this do this and then you
know
but just because you can even write out
the instructions and like in principle
or in a reduced way it might work but
then still it's like running on your
machine.
So that's like the kind of high
integrity
total learning direction where we have
the executable simulation running on
your computer in one or more language.
Then the pseudo code kind of abstraction
taking us towards more of like a
notation driven formalism driven
possibly provable setting on the
analytical side.
And then the natural language is good to
have like descriptive and narrative and
kind of more context driven ways of
thinking about it. But these are all
like different views into these
processes.
And then 3.5 kind of abruptly ends
after that algorithm
and leaves with 3.6
which is
a summary and conclusion step.
However, the last paragraphs, um,
give a really nice history of machine
learning and computer statistics
direction
and help connect some dots between like,
um, the 1990s and early 2000s machine
learning and computer stats literature.
Fraser?
>> Yeah, no, I just I just wanted to second
all that. But before, uh, we did, I
wanted to briefly
say, you know, what okay, with respect
to expectation maximization, how it
again gets around the problem of the
fact that we no longer suppose we can
observe hidden states and therefore
learn a mapping is we do these two steps
of the expectation and then we do
maximization. So, what is expectation?
In expectation, we assume we know what
the parameters are. We start out with
some bad setting of the parameters. And
then we predict what the hidden states
would be if those parameters were true.
But then once we have the that initial
prediction for what the parameters are
given some setting of the
uh, or sorry, what the hidden states are
given some some setting of the
parameters, we can use that prediction
to now perform maximization. So, we we
take the argmax of that distribution
with respect to the parameters and we
can update our parameters. And then we
can just cycle this process,
um, in an iterative fashion, a little
bit like gradient descent in the sense
that it's iterative. So, you have to do
this process a couple of times, you
know, you can't just kind of do one and
done. Um, and you know, we'll we'll
we'll stop after some after the
the the likelihood stops changing
very much. So, with a log likelihood.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> And then one kind of detail on that,
like incremental fitting
is this is the the difference with a
convex versus a non-convex optimization.
So, convex optimization is like a bowl.
There's just one bottom point. And
sometimes it's a very shallow bowl
um
or other times it's more of like a a
narrow one, but like whether you go in
one direction or another if you just
incrementally tighten each thing, you
will get to the same single attractor.
And so in that case, you basically just
plug and chug and then ask like when
does the the when does when does our
movement small enough to disregard and
like consider that we found this one
attractor.
So the L2 norm
or like the the sum of squares, which is
used in the classical regression
that's an example of a convex
optimization problem.
So you can initiate it kind of
haphazardly and cuz you're always going
to get to that same basin no matter
where you drop in on that bowl.
However, more complicated situations or
non-convex optimization
is a situation where like depending on
where you're dropped in, you might get
to a different attractor.
And there's like a huge number of
considerations in that situation like
for rugged fitness landscapes or rugged
energy landscapes because where you
start and the temperature and all these
other features can lead to you having
wildly different outcomes based upon
essentially finding a local maxima
that may or may not be the global
maxima.
So like some of those things are going
to come up again and how does free
energy fit into this like supervised and
unsupervised
framework? How does it fit into convex
and non-convex optimization
for one and for more dimensions?
Those are all going to kind of come up.
But that's where
chapter three
kind of closes
is with those discussions of um
Diane Abbott
Raois Garamani
the '90s and the 2000s
where some of these like computer
statistics plus linear Gaussian math
was being um
brought together.
And then the last part of the last
paragraph
is basically going to motivate
the variational free energy
minimization.
So, that's what is going to get picked
up on in chapter four.
Any last comments
or or ideas or questions for three?
Otherwise, we'll close recording and
just hang out for a few more minutes.
But, also check out the slides that
Andrew has made
and the that um Fraser and others adding
content to the top. There's good
learning
paths.
Good structured learning paths and you
can always um
like add a comment in Coda
if you want to ask someone to unpack
something or you can ask questions or
you could you could upgrade the kind of
more haphazard stuff.
Or you could just add your own notes
during the meeting or after the meeting
like on your own times.
Note upgrade these and and add your own
thoughts in in the questions or in
anywhere else. Andrew?
>> Yeah, thanks. I will I'll try to be
brief. Um as far as the um
with respect to some of what Daniel just
said a moment ago
um with gradient descent. So, uh given
what what we're thinking about these the
convex problem situation where we're
like generally guaranteed to find the
same attractor, um
the for those who have been looking at
the algorithm for gradient descent
notice the the step size, the kappa uh
parameter uh which is kind of how how
big of a step do we take in the
direction of of the gradient that we're
we're following based on finding the
negative log likelihood. Um you can you
can think of like, well, in the in the
convex situation, um it seems like
somewhat trivial and it'll just kind of
change how quickly you eventually reach
that that sort of trough as we as we
descend. However, in the non-convex
case, which is what we're going to be
seeing like very frequently in
real-world settings, not always but
quite often,
um
you can see how that step that having
too big or too small of a step size
can can have a major impact. And so,
whenever you have a a huge step size,
you can actually overshoot kind of the
direction of a global minima or even the
local minima that you're on your way
towards, and kind of go too far, so to
speak. You kind of you kind of jump over
the valley and kind of miss the the
bottom of it. And then and then the
other way around, if your step size is
too small, it could take you a near
infinite amount of time to actually
reach a local minima eventually, right?
You can take the the smallest of step
sizes when in fact there's a giant hill
before you. That's going to take a very
long time to descend. So, I just want to
give a little bit more context on the
kappa
parameter there, and um
yeah, that's that's essentially all all
I wanted to say. Yeah, thanks.
>> Awesome. Okay.
I'll stop recording there, but feel free
to
stay for a few minutes if you have
anything else. So,
thank you.